dans trois semaines le 17 juin
précisément sera donné le coup d'envoi
du baccalauréat avec l'épreuve de
philosophie une période où la mémoire
est mise à rude épreuve
si certains assimilent des connaissances
tout au long de l'année d'autres
pratiquent le bachotage comprenez
apprentissage express en vue de l'examen
pourtant on a coutume de dire qu'il vaut
mieux s'y prendre tôt alors qu'en est-il
vraiment comment fonctionne notre
mémoire c'est le dossier de cette
édition
il est signé mallory ahounou lorraine
christophe lourd c'est la dernière ligne
droite
plus que trois semaines avant de se
frotter au bac dans cette bibliothèque
une question pour tous les candidats
comment mais comment retenir tout ça on
trouve les tortues parti attend et les
lièvres qui me sur le dernier moment ça
tient peut-être là faut vraiment je
speed fois le portrait non bah ça marche
pas trop mal
on espère que cette pcc bachoter c'est
le fait de préparer un examen rapidement
mis intensément sans approfondir sa
suffit-il pour décrocher le bac pour le
savoir il faut comprendre comment
fonctionne notre mémoire au plus tôt nos
mémoires
car chacun semble avoir une idée précise
de ce qui lui permet d'apprendre ces
visuels je retiens vraiment la tâche et
que je lis quoi je me fiche réguler mais
qu'ils consentent les échos j'apprends
par carte
mais des fois j'apprends juin deux jours
avant mais au final je m'en sors dit en
fait nos mémoires fonctionne un peu
comme un ordinateur
notre mémoire à court terme c'est
l'écran elle permet de rassembler ses
idées d'organiser deux rangées des
informations mais elle n'a qu'une faible
capacité voilà pourquoi on apprend bien
qu'à petite dose
ensuite intervient la mémoire à long
terme notre disque dur
les données sont stockées classé
encodées dans des modules spécial quand
nous avons plusieurs mémoires il n'y a
pas une méthode d'arak
en gros il y à des méthodes pour chaque
mémoire par exemple pour la mémoire
lexical c'est le fameux parker qui était
décrié une époque mais qu'il faut
revaloriser pour apprendre la
carrosserie des mots font les écrire
plusieurs fois faut faire des fiches
faut se faire un petit lexique c'est la
mémoire que l'on alimente lorsque l'on
bat shot mais le par coeur
ne suffit pas il faut enrichir notre
mémoire sémantique celle qui conserve le
contexte les abstractions les concepts
la pire erreur réviser la fiche ou la
synthèse d'un camarade
c'est comme si vous alliez à la
bibliothèque et que vous preniez les
fichiers en quelque sorte avec les
fiches des livres pensant vous avez les
livres eux mêmes vous n'aurez que les
titres mais à l'intérieur vous saurez
pas remplies quant à la mémoire imagi il
faut faire des schémas les apprendre
plusieurs fois comme un enfant qui qui
redessine plusieurs fois un dinosaure
d'être une infection tout comme l
ordinateur mais un ordinateur biologique
organique il s'agit de connexions entre
neurones yeux pour retenir une
information une seule connexion ne
suffit pas d'où l'importance à la
répétition
lorsque l'on perçoit une information des
courants électriques parcours nos
neurones mais pour la retenir
durablement
il faut créer de nouveaux réseaux de
connexion au lieu que ce soit des
briques et du ciment
ce sont des protéines ce sont des modes
des hormones de croissance et lors qu'il
va falloir manger il va falloir dormir
pour que quand le cerveau déconnecte de
la réalité les prolongements se fasse
donc il faut du temps du temps un luxe
que certains ne peuvent plus autoriser
pour eux le bachotage permettra sûrement
d'éviter la page blanche le jour j après
c'est une autre affaire construction et
l'entretien de la boucle très bien à qui
des savoirs peuvent être restitués des
années plus tard avec le bachotage 95%
des connaissances auront disparu dans la
semaine qui suit